so hello everyone my name is Patrick Wu
I'm gonna be talking about single page
applications at scale
so gonna turn out that flux capacitor
and yeah with 1.21 gigawatts we should
get started but a little bit about me
I'm a software development manager at
AWS we're building something super
secret confidential stuff for project
called beehive and I love basketball and
I love movies from the 80s and also we
are a sponsor so super excited to be
really helping to contribute to this
community super excited about all the
speakers here and yeah but what do I
mean by Spa at scale like what do I mean
by single page applications at scale
well our project is about two hundred
thousand lines of code and this is not a
codified compressed version but this is
like pre transpiled versions of our
actual applications with over 50
front-end engineers working on the
project across Seattle San Francisco
Cupertino and Vancouver so we have a
very distributed team we're all very
very very excited about our launch but
we had a few bumps along the way so
let's go back in time and I want to talk
to you about our top five lessons
learned so far
lesson one was first getting to know our
customers so a lot of the times as
engineers we're working or like how this
works and it works it works on my
machine it works on Chrome I'm good
right but actually our customers are
also on edge Firefox Safari and I just
found out maybe some of them are a
beaker today so cross browser
compatibility is an actual thing and you
might say well Patrick these are
evergreen browsers they all complied
right they all should work right well
actually on we face this problem
recently we're trying to get our
performance metrics working and on
Firefox version 62 62 we observe without
observer was throwing an error right and
we had to solve that so we had to
actually
fix that and address that for that issue
but they addressed it in version 63 but
60 is actually long term support and
you're saying well that's not they
solved in a version 63 right so that
should that should do the job but
actually on some corporate environments
not everyone has the latest version of
that particular browser so we have to
really think about those users as well
as we're building something at scale the
other thing is operating system issues
so Mac PC we use libraries and
frameworks like react view ember I
forgot to include that thing it angular
Babel plugins to help address cross
browser browser compatibility issues but
don't think that things will just work
and you know this is the thing that we
really learned a prime example was we
didn't know scroll bars display on PCs
we're all on Macs and so we have to
manually enable having it display by
default on Mac which was you know you're
saying well that's not a big issue right
but actually if we use a virtualized
scroll this kind of happens that one
pixel deviation was actually causing
performance issues where the virtualized
list was just kept on moving up and down
and all of the people on on the business
side who had pcs were complaining about
our app not functioning so yeah we had
to really consider that operating
systems the other thing was testing for
great experiences also include slow
connections right so what's awesome with
the chrome dev tools I know many of you
are familiar with this but this was
really revealing for us was people are
on slower connections that are not Wi-Fi
and high-speed so we had really had to
test to see if our actual application
functions on slower connections on a 3G
connection etc the other thing was to
even think about the actual machines so
we have as engineers high-powered
MacBook Pros and that's awesome but some
people are also on slower machines so
really thinking about throttling our CPU
to really cut simulate those
environments so there's also some great
tools that we really learned about to
test connectivity and some of those
tools are an open source project called
webpage tests that we run internally to
really test
our application so to simulate like a
cable connection or a 3G connection etc
and then another really cool tool that
we really learned was lighthouse so that
was also allowing us to kind of see
simulated experience as well and it has
a really great accessibility score which
is really awesome as well the last
second lesson that we learned was about
documentation documenting our code so
one of the reasons we learned that was
as we've got new engineers again 50
engineers and we're keep growing and we
have to keep shoulder tapping people
like what does this component do and
documentation is absolutely pivotal to
the project but it's really hard it's
hard to maintain it's hard to understand
and it's difficult to scale like you
would change a particular function and
you wouldn't go back to your sort the
documentation to actually update it it
happened way too frequently so we
thought how can we solve this problem
one of the things we we introduced was
and I know some people might might not
like this but we actually you know ended
up using typescript and talking
typescript was actually helped us with
doc you like having documentation in
code because it allows for
self-documenting code by providing great
IDE support like the autocomplete on on
that where for our props were pretty
amazing type checking misspelling a
component name would help us with
surface those things a lot quicker
required props provide a nice error
message and then helps us easily
refactor by renaming our components so
it's not like a search and replace but
it'll actually help us rename our
components for the ones that were
actually working on the other thing was
that typescript interfaces allows us to
be explicit about our component props
and surface details about a components
for all consumers so one of the things
that we do is we have distributed teams
and when we talk about the components
that we're gonna build we talk about it
through our interfaces that we first
build so that was kind of a really
helpful thing for us to kind of document
so this all goes back to you know that
awesome book that we all might have read
which is clean code but the actual
author of the code of this quote is Gary
bouche not Uncle Bob and it's clean code
as simple indirect and clean code should
read like well print pros so and that's
what we're hoping
you move more towards by adopting
typescript but that's great for our
engineering teams but it doesn't really
work for some of our business
stakeholders and our designers that we
work with and interact with so how can
we all be on the same page as well so
the thing that we adopted was a
storybook storybook for our react
components rocks and it's super awesome
it allows us to host documentation about
our components it provides a single
source of truth for designers product
owners and our engineers so one of the
problems is why this was really pivotal
for us was we would get a spec and it's
continuously iterating and I would I
would talk to the designer said hey Bob
like what's the what's the what's the
file is this the actual file they're
like yeah that's that's the actual final
file I'm like are you sure this is the
actual final file all right let me reach
out to Sandra and the Sandra's like no
this is the ultimate final file for sure
and there's no I I don't know why they
don't have code versioning maybe they do
but they don't have a git for designer
so it was really hard to find the source
of truth so that was really challenging
at least for us so what we ended up
doing is story book was allowed allowed
for a great workflow with our design
systems and our single source of truth
so what we we have is we have
incorporated Airbnb react sketch app and
we could generate sketch symbols from
our actual react components to share
with the design teams so engineer would
build a react component generators
guests assembled hand that off to design
team and they continues to iterate upon
that hand that off to us and then we can
continuously increment upon that and
actually deploy that to production and
again that's kind of a single source of
truth so that everyone's on the same
page and the beautiful part it's version
controlled by a git
so that's awesome as well lesson three
is tests this might be obvious but it's
actually one of the most like
foundational pieces for us like testing
might seem obvious easy but I emphasize
this as a lesson learned because it
helped us gain confidence in our code a
lot of times we would deploy to prod and
we didn't really have too much
confidence because we we thought I
worked on a machine again like the cross
browser compatibility issues but we had
we reduced a lot introduced a lot of
regressions
reduce the time to first commit for our
new hires so we would get new hires and
they would because the code was you know
fairly well tested it was actually
easier for them to on board and you know
within the first one to two days they
were actually able to commit and we have
a foundational base as well also it
reduces having to paying different
engineers to try to find out what's
going on and the testing framework that
we ended up using was just jess is
actually really great for what we do it
enables us to write unit tests with Jess
with enzyme it also allows us to write
integration tests and it also allows us
to have components tap shot tests to
kind of get visibility into whether or
that particular component has changed so
this is from testing JavaScript comm
which is an amazing resource but it
basically kind of goes over the
different pieces so with static tests
you know to catch typos and errors we
would actually use typescript for that
unit we're using Jess integration we're
using just again an end to end we're
playing and experimenting with possibly
using Jess with puppeteer but again
puppeteer only is supported on Chrome so
that's kind of one of the issues that
we're kind of looking into so again I
just really want to highlight how
awesome testing JavaScript comm is a
great resource by Kent C Dodds and other
amazing contributors so definitely we're
checking out but things can still break
in production so we have your awesome
pipeline test right you got hey you know
from you know this particular
environment to this particular
environment to prod like it went through
code coverage I got 80% I'm good
integration tests they're all passing
and my interim tests are passing so I
should be good and I don't have to worry
about prod and actually as an
engineering manager this is my interview
question right so pro tip here things
can still break in production and we
need to still think about our customers
while they're in production so what do
we do we actually have monitors and
alarms to provide visibility into our
production health for applications to
ensure that the deployments and the
dependencies are there so for example
your CDN might go down don't you want to
get visibility into whether that
actually happens and that's kind of one
of the
that we learn as well and the other
thing is we just we were very focused on
our customers we don't want to kind of
have them be our manual QA team so again
that's the reason why we're focused on
monitoring so now we get we use
specifically cloud watch in our case AWS
right so that helps us collect monitor
and act and analyze on our actual
metrics because as Kyle Stinson
functional light JavaScript mentions
code that you cannot trust is code that
you don't understand and I always say
also in the same like theme code that
you do not test or you haven't tested
it's really code that you don't really
understand as well so that's one of the
things that we learn all right less than
four yakhni now I don't know if any of
you are familiar with the term but it's
popular term coined among the
engineering communities but it means you
ain't gonna need it and as engineers we
kind of have a tendency to fall into
tunnel vision we tend to get stuck in
tunnel vision over optimizing like I you
know this has to really I'm trying to
reduce time to interact is I'm trying to
get that first meaningful paint time
down and I'm trying to reduce I'll look
at the memory heap that Patrick this is
ridiculous we need to reduce this is
this is a and we just kind of rathole
into this particular protect perspective
instead of like seeking feedback early
and often in topic pieces so just like
in your code reviews where you have an
atomic commit and you you send out a
code review for that and like a pull
request whatever and it's an atomic bite
size piece and you want to seek feedback
early and huffed it so that you're not
creating a massive like 20 page code
review right or pull requests so that it
actually helps provide context in the
same sense in terms of our deployments
we want to really think about the the
features that we're building yes I do
believe performance is important but
first you got to capture metrics on that
to you want to get it into like these
tiny atomic pieces so you can get
feedback early from your customers to
know how to move forward because your
customers and the business are eager to
help avoiding wasting dev cycles that's
kind of the things that we learn so all
we need to do is really just stop and
because who knows uh-huh you might have
already built something really cool
right
one one one note about this slide is I
always wondered this kid really happy
that he broke the the scooter but I mean
he looks kind of happy about getting a
skateboard but again yeah anyways all
right
the biggest lesson and you know I think
if you take away anything of those four
lessons that that we learned that I
really want to share with this group is
that is this one and it just take away
this biggest lesson and that is to be
kind rewind right so you know earlier in
the day there used to be a place where
we would go right to a place and you
would you would just go through the
aisles and pick out something like a
nice movie and then you you go to the
checkout line grab a patch pack of sour
patch kids and maybe a pop and then you
go home and then you you you enter this
little block thing into this other
device and you hit play and boom you're
able to watch an amazing movie and it
was awesome and at the end of it there's
this always on this on this the
particular thing you would see be kind
rewind and you know because you want to
be thoughtful about that next person
who's gonna want to enjoy this movie you
would actually be kind and rewind most
of the time unless you're super lazy and
the reason I harp on this is because you
know a lot of us as engineers they you
know in my case I met amazing
engineering managers and mazing
technical leads amazing software
engineers who were showed empathy and
was able to kind of work with me they
were like you know when they showed
empathy when they were reviewing my code
they showed empathy when I was trying to
learn something really complex like
maybe even webassembly
they were there they showed empathy and
compassion and I think a lot of times
maybe as these things are evolving we
might lose out on that so like one of
the things I like to remind our
engineering teams is to continue to
continue to show that empathy we work
with a diverse group of people that are
50 engineers and I think you know one of
the things we like to do is just make
sure that we're not too
emotional about the our code review
process yeah you get a twenty page CR
and you might want to just be a little
more empathetic about you know that
process of how you review that code but
also when it comes to like pair
programming and taking the time to
actually help other engineers getting to
understand a particular function so yeah
that's the biggest lesson I hope
everyone takes away from from at least
what I'm presenting on and that's
actually it that's my presentation so
thank you everyone we're out of time
also right next right next to us is our
AWS lounge you can meet our awesome
other engineering managers and we're
hiring so hit us up thank you
[Applause]